good morning everyone thanks for making
it here through the snow and sleet you
will be quote unquote rewarded with with
a cool little puzzle that has put both
recreational value as well as a deep
connection to the most popular sorting
algorithm or at least the most commonly
used sorting algorithm called quicksort
and so what we have up here is what I
call the disorganized handyman puzzle I
this is not a puzzle of my invention but
I called it this because I think at some
point when I read this I it was a
carpenter who had a bunch of nuts and
bolts in his bag and they were all mixed
up so so rather than having these that
the nuts attached to the bolts
he was disorganized and the nuts and
bolts were separate and then they all
got mixed up together in a bag okay now
obviously all puzzles are a little bit
contrived and so we're going to assume
here that there's a hundred different
nuts and 100 associated bolts and these
two hundred objects are all mixed up
into this one bag that the carpenter is
carrying and not only that each of the
bolts is unique in terms of its size and
as I mentioned there is an Associated
not associated with each each unique
bolt and so as you can imagine the goal
of this puzzle is going to be finding
the most efficient way of creating some
organization in this bag by attaching
each nut to the corresponding bolt or
vice versa
right and you can assume that there's no
ambiguity
because of the uniqueness of the nuts
and the bolts and there's a hundred
pairs waiting to be discovered and you
can try to make that process as
efficient as possible as with all of the
puzzles that we look at here there's
going to be a naive / straightforward
way of doing this if you're going to go
ahead and figure that out pretty quickly
I'll be going to analyze the complexity
of that or how long it takes for a
specific example of a hundred nuts and a
hundred bolts and then we're going to
scratch our heads and try and do better
all right and as I mentioned obviously
there's going to be some programming
associated with this and we're not going
to represent you know nuts and bolts in
in in in programs or codes we're going
to switch gears and talk about sorting
once we're done with this puzzle good
the only way that you are the carpenter
if you're the carpenter's helper have of
checking I to see that and not attaches
to a bolt is to try it out okay and the
nuts and bolts are different enough in
size that even if you had your eyes
closed or was a dark room you could if
they're not attaches to the bolt it
would screw on perfectly and if it is if
the bolt is smaller than they're not it
would just go through and it would be
obvious that the bolt is smaller than
the knot and if not is smaller than the
ball it will also be obvious because the
bolt you know wouldn't go through it
right which makes perfect sense from a
physical standpoint right we've all
tried this before we've had maybe not
all of you but I've certainly had
occasion to to discover pairs of of nuts
and bolts though it was never you know
100 of them right but so that's kind of
a little bit contrived as I said alright
good so the setup is clear we're good on
the setup excellent so what is the
straightforward way of doing this
someone yeah funny back there right we
could choose a not at random try every
different bolt or choose a bolted random
and try every different nut right and
we're guaranteed in this case that there
is a pairing and so after we do that we
can put this paired nut and bolt aside
and we've shrunk the problem down to one
less than the original problem if I
started out with a hundred pairs that
are not paired together but there's a
hundred knots and a hundred volts then I
get one pair which is a correct pair and
I have 99 knots left in 99 bolts left
right and I keep going right perfectly
reasonable way of doing things and I let
me show you how that would work these
slides were making made by my daughter's
many years ago you know back when they
listen to me right I have fat chance of
getting them to do any work for me
anymore but they are busier than they
were I guess years ago at least I
pretend to be and there you go you end
up in this particular example which
obviously has many fewer than a hundred
nuts and bolts you end up checking this
and in the worst case how many
comparisons would I had to do but would
I have had to do if I had 100 nuts and a
hundred bolts in the worst case I would
have to I have to do all 100 because I
might just have gotten unlucky like I
said I mean we're not a bawling this at
all
I you could probably prune the search a
little bit with respect to putting aside
not having to do an exact comparison but
let's just say that even looking at and
not as opposed to even touching it with
the bulk that you've chosen is in fact a
comparison you know you're just
eyeballing it as opposed to physically
touching the bolt and not together and
we're going to call that a comparison
and if you do that and if you make that
assumption then obviously you're going
to have to look at all
100 knots if you have a random bolt in
the worst case okay you might get lucky
on average it might be only 50 you're
not going to do that type of analysis
here so so that's good and what is the
complexity in terms of the growth rate
of this this particular algorithm if I
had n nuts and bolts then I do n
comparisons in the worst case to find
the first pair and when I say first pair
I mean the correct pairing that's
associated with they're not in the bolt
and you know what happens yeah Kevin you
have a question it's it's absolutely
less than n square in the in in in terms
of numerics the the growth rate is a
slightly different question right it's
related obviously and so I if you I do
this and you get the first pair you now
have a problem that had that is of size
n minus 1 right and so in this case how
many comparisons am I going to make when
I have n minus 1 nuts and n minus 1
balls in the worst case I'm gonna do n
minus 1 comparisons right and then I
keep going down and and I you you could
you could argue that at the at the very
end when I have two nuts and two bolts
one comparison if I assume that this was
a perfect set of nuts and bolts that we
had all pairs right at the beginning I
you you could argue that that that small
problem corresponding to two nuts and
bolts can be solved using
one comparison and you immediately know
which not pairs with which bolt and the
other one as well but you know let's
call it a conformation comparison and
essentially say you need two comparisons
here and and one here you can obviously
shave a number I little bit out of out
of this but this goes back to Kevin is
right it's less than n square if you
look at it numerically but the growth
rate is n square because we know that n
plus n minus 1 plus n minus 2 better dot
2 plus 1 is n times n plus 1 divided by
2 and sure you could you could take this
one off and this would become n times n
minus one big divided by 2 but that
growth rate is N squared grows as N
squared right so if you had a hundred
nuts and a hundred bolts you're talking
about something of the order of 5,000
comparisons right if you want to do it
numerically and it grows as N squared if
you had a thousand then it would be a
thousand times a thousand was the
million divided by two that's five
hundred thousand so that is astronomical
in terms of its growth you don't want to
do that right obviously a contrived
problem but n square in general then
when you talk about manual labor is is
generally not very good so if we'd like
to improve this right and I we've been
talking about recursion we've been
talking about divide and conquer this is
not divide and conquer in the true sense
in in that it's it you're going to a
smaller problem admittedly but recall I
said divide and conquer is usually used
when you break the problem up into
fractional pieces ok
which means in merge sort for example we
took or the tiling puzzle we took the
courtyard
and we broke it up into four courtyards
so essentially we had four quarters in
the case of the tiling puzzle we had two
halves in the case of mergesort
here we are solving a basically one not
in bolt in the original puzzle and then
we're going from n to n minus one and so
there's many more steps right the one
thing to remember when you think about
complexity is that when you go n to n
divided by 2 to n divided by 4 and then
you keep going and you go all the way
down to 1
this of course when you go like this
there's a linear number of steps but
when you do that how many steps do you
have to get all the way to 1 in relation
if if you start with n how many steps
you have if I had if this were this were
64 or let's just take a simpler one if
this were four how many steps would I
have I would have two steps if this were
eight I'd have three steps and so what's
that formula logarithm log to the base 2
all right so so that's the power of
fractional sizes and this is actually a
very fundamental notion that is going to
appear over and over if you do any
algorithms work or take any algorithms
classes that I divide and conquer is
very efficient because the number of
steps in order to get down to small
problems is relatively small it's it's a
logarithm now if you broke this up into
into three parts and you went to n over
3 etc then this would be log to the base
something else in the log to the base 3
so log to the base 2 came because we
broke it up in you know it and we went
down to half half the size right now
remember of course I mean it's not that
the complexity here it is just
logarithmic it's that you do have two
problems
this is a function of the particular
specific algorithm that corresponds to
divide and conquer but in the case of
merge sort
it's not that we just went from n to n
over two belt we went to n from n to n
over two but there were two n over 2
size problems and but the beauty of of
divide and conquer is if I magically if
I magically broke up the N size problem
and let's go back to our nuts and bolts
into two problems of size n over 2 so
each a problem has n over 2 knots and n
over 2 bolts
okay each problem has I'll repeat that
and over 2 knots and over 2 bolts then
if I used I and and this is magical
right I don't quite know how to do that
yet but if I did that then I think about
what happens with respect to at these
comparisons so I said when n was a
hundred I needed 5,000 comparisons for
this naive algorithm but now if I did
this and I got to n over 2 then I have
50 so I'll call that M equals 50 and
then I have another one which is M
equals 50 and so roughly how many
comparisons what I'd need if I had as
problem of size 50 50 knots and 50 bolts
using our original naive strategy
roughly 1225 right roughly and this
would be 1225 and so so that is 2500 so
of course I don't haven't quite told you
how to do this this is still magic but I
was upfront about it but clearly I've
gotten an improvement if I have this
magic okay and so let's talk about that
let's turn this nuts-and-bolts puzzle or
the solution to this puzzle
and try and figure out a
divide-and-conquer strategy which is
distinctly different from the
brute-force strategy that just reduced
by one all right now villa this was just
going on
so the comparisons in the worst case is
what I just said and it grows as n
squares so Big O n square means it just
grows as n square right that's
asymptotic notation that we won't go
into but you get you understand what
that means now so if I do a
straightforward divide and conquer like
I did with merge sort where I just took
the array and I split it in half right
if I take these nuts and bolts and I
take separate the nuts out you know put
it put 50 on this side 50 on the other
side take the bolts put 50 on this side
and 50 on the other side is that gonna
work no that's not going to work and the
reason is if I do this arbitrary
partition but then I'm let's say that I
take this and the two of you get
together your friends and partners and
you say let's do this in parallel and
save some time you're still going to be
counting the number of comparisons and
so obviously you also would like to
reduce the number of comparisons but you
can't even use a helper here in the
sense that if you'd split this up
obviously this was not fifty and fifty
but three nuts and three bolts on one
side and four and four on the other side
as you can see from this example you I
had a situation where the matching not
was in one pile on the left for a bolt
that was on the right hand side right
and that could happen not just for one
which would kill the process but could
happen for many nut bolt pairs right so
we can't do that right we cannot use the
straightforward divide-and-conquer
approach so so this comes to the first
interesting question that we have here
which is how do we exploit the fact that
all of you are going to help me so I'm
the disorganized carpenter
handyman and and and I'd like to break
this up first into two piles such that I
can go off and send one or more of you
off and and say okay I can guarantee
that this is a sub problem in the sense
that the original problem had all of the
bolts that matched all of the nuts that
were in my pile I want to break it up
and do two problems in this is the magic
that we have we need to figure out this
magic that such that if I give you 50
nuts and 50 bolts and I keep 50 nuts and
50 bolts that you can solve that problem
it is a problem I mean it there's
there's a matching there right for those
50 nuts
you have the 50 bolts in your pile same
thing with me all right so how do I do
that yeah go ahead Josh
no you cannot yeah good question
all right so you you you the only thing
you can do is you know you have you have
a and not in you have a bolt and if it
goes through then the nut is bigger if
it doesn't then the bolt is bigger and
then if it fits exactly you have a match
all right great so yeah go ahead
you know because it fits in perfectly
right if it fits so all the ones that
you just go through all the light goes
through just the hole then you know
those are smaller hole they're bigger
right great excellent
so banana is discovered this notion of
pivoting and pivoting is essentially
something that is best described here in
animation that gives you a divide and
conquer strategy right now I answer
Joshua's question and that is a key
question and I'm not going to violate
the answer to that question I buy I
using some other strategy that that does
not correspond to this not pull check
right so the only thing I can do in this
puzzle is a nutball check but I do get
three potential possibilities whenever I
do a nutball check I do get the
information about a perfect match
whether they're not as smaller or
whether they're not as bigger right and
that's all I need in order to do
pivoting right and so what's going to
happen here is I go ahead and I choose
an arbitrary bolt and if I
I don't even actually need to find the
match before I start this process so
it's a small variant on what gonna throw
set but it's really a pretty small
variant and when I see that this is not
a match and in fact the nut is bigger
then I put the nut on the right hand
side pile okay when I see that they're
not is smaller then I put the nut in the
left hand side pile and I see a match I
just put that aside I don't put it in
either of the piles because I'm going to
actually it turns out I'm not going to
get a pile of 50 and 50 or in this case
I'm actually going to get something like
3 & 3 because I'm gonna get one match
out of it right so in the case of in
general I don't necessarily
I'm not necessarily gonna get equal size
piles so that's actually a little bit of
an issue and we'll get back to that
maybe later
but I will get a matching and I'll get a
pile on the left that is a perfect
problem perfect sub problem there I can
hand it off to any of you and you can go
off and solve it and it'll work and I'll
get a pile on the right same thing for
that right so this was a match but I
don't stop I I don't put the knot in
either of the two piles it's just going
to stay up there and then I keep going
and I make up my right pile and my left
paddle right now I'm not quite done yet
what do I do now yeah back there that's
right so remember I kept the I kept I
I guess you used a different term here
you you used to
I said bold use it's crude that's fine
but we're talking about not here so so
let's go with the nut and this is not
that I put aside I'm going to now
compare that not with this pivot bolt
that I picked which is now set aside and
never have used that again but I'm going
to put that aside and I'm going to
compare each of the bolts with this this
pivot not that I have so the pivot bolt
was picked and I discover the Associated
pivot nut and I now I'm gonna use that
pivot nut which is the the matter that I
have up here the light green one and
then I'm going to do the same thing and
all of this does not violate the answer
to Josh's question and it's going to do
exactly the right thing I in terms of
giving me by giving me two piles that
are beautiful problems
that are gonna be solvable all right
there's nothing that's stopping me from
repeating this process then we talk
about divide and conquer usually we talk
about recursion and we talk about
repeatedly doing divide and conquer when
I wrote this up here in terms of I the N
size problem turned into two and over
two problems well each of those n over
two problems I could turn into two and
over four problems so I can have four
and over fours and so on and so forth
and so I could clearly do that and
especially if n is large then I want to
get at reduction in comparisons and get
this to grow by the way and we won't do
this analysis but rather than growing as
n square you'd you'd like it to grow as
n log n right and that's kind of the
asymptotic analysis that you'll have to
do if you take a class like six double
oh six but the general sense that you
should take away from this is that
you're gonna have a logarithmic number
of steps and obviously that doesn't
imply a logarithmic number of
comparisons because the number of
subproblems in each of those steps is
doubling initially you had a problem
then you have two subproblems and then
you have four subproblems each of them
are are small in size but add together
assuming these problems are are n over 2
and n over 2 then you can get something
that's substantially smaller than n
square a namely n log n ok and you can
do that numerically and I don't want to
get into that too much but be happy to
talk to you about this after lecture or
during office hours there's a couple of
caveats one of them is and there's no
guarantee here if I pick a random pivot
bolt that I'm actually going to get n
over 2 and n over 2 it's going to be 1
less than that maybe it'd be n over 2
and n over 2 to minus 1 I could get
something if I
picked a large pivot bolt I might get a
very skewed pair of piles right one of
them could have 80 in them 80 nuts and
bolts in them and the other one could
have 20 nuts and bolts in them okay so
that's something to worry about and we
won't worry about that
but we'll talk about it when we move to
sorting which is what we're gonna do in
the in just a couple of minutes
all right so people buy the solution to
the nuts and bolts puzzle
clearly it's gonna give you some
efficiency if you pick a middling size a
bolt and maybe you can eyeball that it's
a little bit of a violation of what
we've talked about but but you could you
could clearly I mean you let's assume
that that you can make out the
difference between you know something
that's as thick as this and their finger
and then you pick something in the
middle and then you can get two large
piles that are roughly equal in size
from the original really large pile and
at least in the at the beginning you
could probably get in the context of
this puzzle piles that are roughly
similar in size right and after that it
doesn't really matter once you've broken
things up so n is not a hundred but you
know n is more like five or ten at that
point it doesn't really matter what
strategy you use because the numbers
aren't very different depending
regardless of the strategy okay so so
good alright so I promised you a
relationship to sorting and obviously we
want to do some programming here and it
turns out that just like we had merge
sort which was a divide and conquer
algorithm it turns out this pivoting
strategy it turns into a strategy for
divide and conquer that is quite
different from merge sort but is equally
applicable to sorting numbers okay and
so let me remind you what merge sort was
and then I'm going to contrast merge
sort with quicksort which is a pivot
based sorting algorithm right so forget
about nuts and bolts we're now down to
boring numbers integers and we want to
just
these numbers in ascending order okay so
if I have a bunch of numbers and I want
to sort these in ascending order
mergesort would say I'm going to go
ahead and break it up into halves okay
and let's just do one level of recursion
you know if with all of these things you
can always do more but these problems
aren't large enough that you really want
to do that in this example and the
important thing is you just broke it
into half you know bit it was easy the
split was easy you sliced the list
splice the list what have you right and
you assume that somehow you can sort
this in ascending order in this case it
you need to go to that and then you sort
this in ascending order so you go like
that and then you need to do a merge and
we used what we call the two-finger
algorithm to do the merge that
essentially says I'm going to assume
that this array is sorted and this array
is sorted and I'm gonna put pointers up
at the beginning of piece to erase and
I'm gonna do comparisons and I'm
essentially going to assume that I have
a blank array of size 6 blank list of
size 6 and I'm gonna be writing into
this blanket ray the result of the
comparison that is which one is less in
the comparisons so I'm gonna get minus
31 and then I compare 0 with minus 4 and
I'm gonna get minus 4 0 etcetera
etcetera all right so that was our merge
and the important thing to remember is
that our merge algorithm was I had an
easy divide step and it had a more
difficult step at that
corresponded to taking the sub arrays
that were sorted and and the work was
all in the merge okay putting the things
together because the divide obviously is
just like chop right um
now as you can see from the
nuts-and-bolts division was non-trivial
right division required pivoting okay
but there was no real merge after that I
mean once I hand it off let's say do you
not release 50 nuts and bolts after I
did the work in pivoting and I kept 50
nuts and bolts as well we were done I
mean he's just no maybe I wanted the
nuts and bolts back and I don't wanted
to run away with it but it wasn't like I
had to process anything that he gave me
back right if he paired them up then I
didn't have to process that right so um
this is merge sort the quicksort
algorithm which I'll now describe to you
is divide and conquer a two way to
divide and conquer at same as merge sort
but it kind of flips the the work and it
does more work upfront before the
division and then this at little or no
work at the end all right so what
happens here is the way we're going to
think about quicksort is we're going to
choose a pivot you can have some array
here and I can go ahead and just call
these abcdefg and I'm gonna choose a
pivot and in the code that I'm going to
show you we're just going to go ahead
and choose the last element we assume
that this is in random order you're
gonna choose the last element of this
array as the pivot right and what did we
do with the pivot back in our
nuts-and-bolts example we someone what
would you do with the pivot
yeah yeah just basically spliced around
it you compared it with but if we took
the pivot bolt and stand in this case of
the puzzle you compare it with the nuts
here we don't have nuts and bolts we
just have numbers and so you're gonna
take that pivot and you're gonna start
comparing it with the other numbers and
you're exactly right in that we're going
to get to the point where we have to
splice around it which isn't your
standard you know python splicing
because that requires contiguous
locations right but what you want to do
is you want to get to a situation where
you have something like this where you
have G somewhere in the middle and all
elements less than G are to the left and
let's assume they're all unique elements
all elements greater than G are to the
right okay so this is exactly a pivoting
around G right so this is it's referred
to as pivoting around G okay now the
nice thing here when you do this and is
that you can go off and you can fix the
location of G in fact G's location just
like the pair the nut bolt pair was
corresponding to the pivot nut and the
pivot bolt was determined during the
pivoting step and you never had to check
whether never had to discover that pair
again you can put that pair aside the
location of G the pivot chosen in the
final sorted array is determined by this
pivoting step okay that makes sense
um and so so this location whatever that
indexes you know it might be right in
the middle it might be a little bit
skewed but that location is determined
and if you did this with roughly equal
piles if you will or equal sides if
there were a 100 elements here you might
see you know 50 odd here and you know 40
or over there right and of course if G
happen to be the largest number then G
would be all the way to the right right
so so there's that
20 month and so but this is the divide
step so the divide step is the pivoting
step and then you can go off and sort
its each of those sub lists right
because those less than G are not
necessarily in ascending order right you
just you know dump them there's still
work to be done and then the greater
than G likewise they're not necessarily
in ascending order but I you know that
there's 42 elements in corresponding to
less than G and you can go sort that
array and those are going to be the
first 42 elements of your final array
right and the G is going to be at the
43rd position and then the ones that are
greater than G are going to be to the
right of that all make sense right
yeah go ahead Fadi that's right so
that's pathological now it turns out
that amazingly I in order to avoid that
situation when people use quicksort in
practice which is essentially this
algorithm that I described
they take the array that they're given
and they actually randomize it they
actually make it they shake it up right
it's it's like you get these nuts and
bolts and you want to close your eyes
and you want to pick up and not that's
middling in size and you know maybe all
the small ones are up at the top and the
big ones are down at the bottom you want
things in the middle so you go to shake
shake shake
you know you randomize and then you go
stick your hand in but halfway through
the pile and pick out pick up enough
I'll pick up a ball right that's kind of
what happens here so so quicksort it
turns out and I'll just say this and if
this doesn't make sense
ask me later but it should give you some
intuition I the random randomized
quicksort where you have this random
input and you have some probabilistic
guarantee that you're picking a pivot
that is middling in size in terms of an
integer size is going to be n log n in
complexity but the worst-case complexity
of quicksort is
actly as you said it's n square okay but
you know that's really not something
that you need to understand deeply to
understand about either the puzzle are
the rest of this lecture you do get a
sense of as long as you have a sense of
if you pick something in the middle and
these piles are roughly equal in size
I'm gonna get some improvement right the
guarantee that the piles are roughly
equal in size all the way down to the
depths of recursion is a difficult one
to achieve in a deterministic way but
it's not hard to achieve in a
probabilistic way right by doing this
randomization you had another question
yeah that is the rest of the lecture
okay which is only 10 minutes left but
okay so that's the that's the rest of
the lecture right so one of the things
that I said here I said a blank list of
size six okay so what merge sort
requires in order for merge sort to be
efficient you needed auxilary storage
that corresponded to at the size of the
list because right at the first level of
recursion and when you got to erase that
were n over 2 and n over 2 and they were
both sorted and you had it I had to
merge the two together to create the
final result corresponding to the sorted
array you ended up requiring storage
that was N in size in order to actually
do this two-finger algorithm and
compared the minus 30 ones with the
zeros and then write them into this
array right now the obvious way of
taking this and going to here is code
that I'm going to show you that is easy
to write and it requires a blank list as
well okay you just I mean the easy way
to do that and I'll just show you the
code because it's easier to show you the
code as opposed to waving my hands here
and potentially confusing people but let
me show you first the quicksort
divide-and-conquer which is abs
totally trivial I mean just like
mergesort was but pivot partition is
this step here okay this is the pivoting
step and and this is what that procedure
does right so we'll get to that in just
a second but the rest of it is simply
I'm going to go ahead and once I do the
pivot put partition I have something
that looks like this and then I just go
off and run quicksort on this and
quicksort on that and I'm doing that and
on the array itself it's it's just like
I have this array and I'm just saying
I'm gonna call quicksort with the
indices that are associated with the
beginning and the end of this array and
then I'm going to call quicksort with
the indices that are that begin with the
beginning and the end of this array and
as long as and that same array is going
to be my final output right so
everything is done and at the term
that's used here is in place right so in
place sorting and insertion sort which
is also n square and a few other things
are in place sorting algorithms which
essentially say look I need to sort all
of you if you know in some hour some ran
some way right you know perhaps by age
or something and um you know I don't
want need I don't want another room
right I don't want to say he'll who's
the youngest here and then go over to
that room and then you know who's the
next youngest and go over to the room
etc I just want you to start swapping
positions here and we're all gonna be in
this room and somehow you know we're
gonna get sorted right so that's in
place and when I haven't an array that
corresponds to integers I don't want
another blank list or blank array and
use that storage and so that answers
your question
at the top level as to why quicksort is
used and it's used because the memory
requirements of quicksort are
substantially less than the memory
requirements of merge sort and in fact
you can do this a pivoting step using
one integer as storage and you need the
original array of course but you needed
that to store all of the numbers and the
auxilary store is the extra storage that
you need is exactly the storage for one
integer where you store the pivot okay
and I'm gonna show you the naive way
which is the
regular quicksort and and that is that a
trivial pivot partition it's not the
clever one which essentially says look
I'm gonna go ahead and I'm going to
create a new array and I are in fact I
have two arrays that are less and more
or two lists together the sizes of less
and more are going to be the size of the
original right maybe minus one but I'm
adding two less and adding two more
depending on whether the element is less
than the pivot or greater than the pivot
and then I'm good so there's that
there's that algorithm which would just
be oh yeah I'm gonna create a new list
here and I'm going to compare a to G and
and then I'm gonna compare you know B to
G etc etc all right
so this does not give you anything this
is an uninteresting algorithm I'm sorry
the implementation this is an
uninteresting implementation okay it is
much more it's it you need to be much
more clever I don't need this anymore to
do this in place okay so what I want to
do is
I gonna take an example here I wanted I
want to be able to take this array and
I'm going to not talk about the
recursive sorting or anything like that
because that's easy right we kind of
know how to do that what I want to do is
I want to choose this as the pivot and I
want to translate that somehow into the
final I pivoted an output which is going
to be 0 minus 31 1/2 6599 whoops
so I have something wrong here so this
should be the other way around 83 right
okay mmm oh I'm sorry I'm sorry
um this is fine this is fine I just need
it I don't need to be sorted okay good
whoo all right I had this I I just
thought I found the first bug in my book
okay so there's probably many bugs in
the book but I don't want to know don't
write so I don't need this to be sorted
yes as a 0 a minus 31 so the key is that
I've discovered this and everything to
the left of that is less than 1 and
everything to the right of that is
greater than 1 and that's the only
requirement that I have and and as I
said I mean I said this to begin with
and then I forgot I said we're not going
to worry about the recursion so clearly
I have to do more work here with with
respect to taking this is set of numbers
and and sorting them in ascending order
etc but what I've done here is I know
that one is fixed in place and one will
never move right and I just do have you
turned this into minus 31 and 0 and I
have to do some reordering here but one
is fixed in place okay now the algorithm
that I have that I'm going to show you
I'm going to show you the code and it's
probably code that I you won't be able
to parse at least in in minutes or
seconds and this code is in place
pivoting okay it's a clever code and
what it does is it has one additional
variable worth of storage that we're
going to call the pivot right so that
you see the variable pivot there and
just using that one additional integer
storage it manages to transform this
array using a linear number of steps
into into this array all right so you
can see that this is non-trivial right I
need to I need to move from here to
there without having this extra storage
if you had extra storage it would be
easy we know how to do that but if you
didn't you have you need this this code
that has an outer while loop you see
while not done and then it's got two
inner while loops in it and it's got a
couple of counters couple of pointers I
should say two indices and you go left
and right and you magically get at this
answer right but there's no magic here
because we have the code up and we can
run it and computers aren't smart so
clearly that that code is doing
something clever and we just need to
understand that all right so I'm gonna
in the couple of minutes I have left
this is the last thing I want to do is I
want to tell you how this code works
okay and it's really pretty code and
it's it's clever code so what I have is
I have two pointers top and bottom so
I'm going to essentially say that top is
all a bottom as zero initially is minus
one but we go ahead and increment it and
top is eight right and so how many I
have nine one two three four five six
nine so so so so top is pointing to the
pivot so this is this is pointing to the
pivot which is top is eight and and
bottom is pointing to to the first
element right so um these two while
loops are essentially going from the
left of the array and going this way
from the from the right of the array so
what we going to do and I and don't
worry about exactly how the code does
this I'm going to show you the way this
array is transformed and the way this
these pointers are changed and then
you'll get a sense of how this code
works right and obviously this
transformation happens in one of those
while loops all right so we have the
pivot corresponding to one and bottom
equals zero and top equals eight what
I'm going to do is
I'm gonna start moving I'm leftward from
i this would be the second inner while
loop I'm gonna start moving oh I'm sorry
I'm going to start I'll start with a bit
with bottom I'm gonna increment bottom
is initially minus one and increment it
to zero and I start moving right word
from the left of the list and try and
find an element that is greater than one
right and that is immediate I realized
that four is greater than one
okay so when I realize that four is
greater than one I'm going to copy over
four and this is doesn't mean that I'm
copying the entire array I'm just going
to copy over four but I'm writing what
the array looks like but that's
important over to here right and you
might say pivot equals one you might say
oh but I over wrote the location one and
I'm like don't worry about it I do have
one stored in my pivot so my pivot has
one in it okay so I haven't lost
anything here it's not like I threw away
any locations I do have that extra
location right so I did this right word
move going from the left now I'm going
to go leftward from the from the from
the right and I'm going to look for
something that is less than one and I'm
going to try and move it so basically
what this algorithm does is it it tries
to find things that are if a is is
greater than G it moves a to the
rightmost part of the array if if and
the same thing if D is less than G then
it moves it to the to the left part of
the array so depending on whether the
comparison to G is greater or less you
want to end up in the edges of the array
and you're going to try and get
the edges of the array to be correct in
the in the sense that they have elements
on the left that are less than the pivot
and the elements on the right that are
greater than the pivot and you try and
get to the middle and when you when
you're two pointers converge your top
and bottom pointers converge you're done
all right so let's do a couple more
steps and and and close this lecture so
I did the right step
now I'm going going rightward and now
I'm going to go leftward and what is the
first element that is less than one I
know less than one zero right yes but
I'm going this way yeah I'm going yeah
I'm glad you pointed that out I needed
to make sure so I went I went right word
the first time and I want to go left
word this time so so this would be so I
I come here and I see I see zero when I
see zero what I'm going to do is I'm
going to transform the array I'll write
this out to make sure I get this right
and so right now I have 465 to minus 31
0 etc and I'm going to go this way and
I'm going to put when I see the zero I'm
going to copy over 0 over here and leave
the 0 in here for a second and there's
no problem here because 4 was copied
over here and so now I overrode 4 with
zero
okay now you kind of see maybe get a
some sense of how this algorithm works
this is the first interesting step where
I took zero and because zero is less
than one as I mentioned I want to jam it
all the way to the left ok just put it
all the way to the left and I'm cool
with losing 4 because 4 is being put all
the way to the right okay now at this
point my bottom and top I'm going to get
modified
my bottom is still zero but the top is 4
because I moved top was 8 and i
decremented a top all the way to the
point where it became 4 and I realized
that 0 was less than 1 and then I copied
over that value over to the to the
bottom you can kind of see the code up
there it it this is actually an output
of that code and I put I put a 0 in here
so that's what my counters look like and
it's only a couple more steps we're
gonna go now go right and I'm going to
go do this again
except that 0 is already taken care of
so now I see 65 clearly I'm going to
have a situation where if I go this way
65 is is greater than the pivot right so
I'm gonna go 0 65 to minus 31 and
because 65 is greater than the pivot I'm
gonna write it into what the top was
which obviously got copied over that way
so I'm gonna have 65 in here 9983 seven
eighty two and four alright so now after
this step bottom equals one and the
reason for that was 65 is in the
location on one and top equals 4 and
then the next one someone want to tell
me what the next one is going to be if I
go left word I'm gonna start from here
top was four so it's pointing at 65 and
I'm looking for looking for something
that I when I go when I go this way I
saw 65 greater than 1 now I'm looking
for something that is less than 1 and
minus 31 is less than 1 correct when I
go this way I'm looking for something
that's less than so so given that is
minus 31 I'm going to copy over - 31 -
what top was pointing to so I have minus
31 to minus 31
sixty-five 9983 seven eight two and four
and at this point I'm gonna have bottom
equals one and top equals three keep
going
one more and I get to the point where I
see 2 2 is greater than 1 0 and minus 31
are less than 1 and so I take 2 and I
copy your copy it over here all right
and now at this point when I do an
increment I realize that top bottom is 2
and top is 3 and in the very next step
bottom will equal top and I'm sitting up
here and so I copy I make 2 I'd write
the pivot into the location that
corresponds to that bottom after the top
got decremented and in that case both
bottom and top are 2 and that index 0 1
& 2 the pivot gets written into it and
so that's exactly what I had which I
wrote right at the beginning all right
so I would say this is probably the most
complicated code from a control flow
standpoint that I've ever shown you this
this algorithm is an in-place algorithm
that does not require any extra storage
and that's exactly why it's so popular
people are sorting billions of elements
in lists and you can't use gigabytes of
storage during the sorting process right
and what this clever strategy tells you
is you don't need all of that storage
you can do things in place and as long
as you choose the pivot reasonably well
you get your average case n log n
complexity which is the same as the
worst case complexity of merge sort so
you have to be a little bit careful with
that